I've arrived in Amsterdam and my goal is
to get to know the Dutch capital from a
different angle than most of the city's
six million foreign tourists instead of
sleeping in one of the 55,000 available
hotel beds I'm going to be staying in a
private room not in a house but on a
houseboat so it with me here my host
said it's the fourth board over here
comes bounding it's 1234 disrepute I
booked the room a few days ago through
the online platform Airbnb I'm really
curious to see how things go our dining
room living room in return for 130 euros
Paula insurance law to sue Silesia are
sharing their home with me for the night
the Dutch Brazilian couple have been
living here for four years in 290 square
meters on board a former freighter it's
one of about 2,500 houseboats in
Amsterdam my room is towards the back
ok so see you guys are wrong yeah yeah
you just know a part of our weekend
Emily and that's quickly how it feels
first I hang out and relax with Paula
and her own for a couple of hours
loading up on Amsterdam tips then they
tell me about being a our B&B hosts
first was an opportunity to meet more
people and yeah I know everybody feels
at home that's what we would like no
full house love that's what we like you
know we left with some friends so they
come as guests then leave his friends
and some of them they even came to our
wedding last year next I decided I
should probably find out a little more
about the city the social media platform
connected users share their talents
whether playing the guitar or sharing
inside information on Amsterdam I make a
date with Molly's in the afternoon for a
private tour of the city I decide I want
to drive to the appointment an app on my
smartphone guides me to the closest car
in a car sharing fleet around 350 of
them are scattered throughout the city
although I like driving it's clear that
Amsterdam is better discovered on a bike
so I decide to get one the rental agency
is easy to find there are an estimated
880,000 bicycles in the city there are
actually more bikes than people but even
the bike is useless for the last stage
I'm glad that crossing to the spot where
I'm supposed to meet my guide is scenic
because there's no sign of molly's when
I get there so my private tour guide
just canceled our little day that we
have it just happens so I will have a
look around
it's time to share my experiences with
my colleagues in Berlin a selfie is in
order
I'm getting hungry now after my walk
around town but rather than dining out
in a restaurant I'll be eating at
someone's home Petra heart cooks about
five times a month for complete
strangers I reserved a place on the
internet just like the couple from
Rotterdam together with her husband she
served up three courses with wine or 428
euros her guests mainly come because of
the cosy atmosphere we got very
well-known man here and we asked him
what why do you come here am I don't you
just go to one of our Michelin star
restaurants or and he said well that's
just it's too too heavy for me I'm get
photographed i will get paparazzi in my
face and i just wanted to have a very
nice private dinner and never
conversation with some real people
guests and hosts can also rate the
experiences online positive reviews make
it more likely that others will have a
nice experience as well
but by the next day I had enough of
sharing I enjoyed the sun on the 40
meter long roof terrace by myself
it was such a beautiful day yesterday
and I think it is because I met people I
wouldn't have met if I would have shared
their house is like here on the board at
dinner tables yesterday and I really
think I've got an impression of
Amsterdam that I would have missed if I
had travelled in a normal way thanks to
sharing I could really be a part of the
Amsterdam vibe